(excited chattering)
(excited screaming)
- Let's celebrate some pooh.
That didn't sound right.
Let's get our singing voices ready.
- Okay.
(shrieking)
Wow, don't sing like that.
♫ It's a small world after all.
♫ It's a small, small world.
(whoosh)
(glass shattering)
(chimes twinkling)
- Good morning Believe Nation.
- [Evan] Wow, that's an excited Nina!
That is one excited Nina.
- Today is,
day five.
- Thought we were going home,
no?
- [Child In Backseat] No, Magic Kingdom.
- We're going to go to the
Entrepreneur Conference,
all day long.
- [Child In Backseat] No!
- [Nina] No.
- No?
No, we're going to go-
- [Child In Backseat] To Disney!
- Going to go set up some new businesses.
- [Nina] Okay, we're going back to?
- Disney World.
- World.
- Yep, we're heading up to Magic Kingdom.
We're going to do some more fun.
The kids are going to behave.
Everything's going to be,
fantastic!
- [Child In Backseat] Maybe, not.
(giggling)
Not,
not maybe.
- And everything's going to be,
fantastic!
- [Child In Backseat] Fantastic!
(light playful music)
- We're a little bit
earlier than yesterday,
we got a better parking spot.
I'll admit, it makes me happy.
(laughing)
The kids have their hats
on and they're ready to go.
Ho!
- Ho!
- Let's get on the tram, get to Disney.
(light playful music)
What's Nina wearing?
Some Believe Gear.
And what's Hayden wearing?
What am I wearing?
The Believe Team.
(light playful music)
- Hey.
- [Evan] You look cute.
I like watching you walk.
Look at Nina speed walking.
(upbeat playful music)
What did you discover Nina?
Ho!
- Eeyore.
Eeyore.
- [Evan] Ee-or.
(laughing)
It's Eeyore.
(upbeat playful music)
Nina's trying to butt in line.
- No, I'm in front I'm not butting in.
(laughing)
(upbeat playful music)
- Let's go.
Let's celebrate some Pooh.
That's didn't sound right.
Alright, Winnie The Pooh!
(cheerful jaunty music)
What did we think kids?
- Awesome.
- Where's Jeffery?
- Right here.
- Hey!
How was it Nina?
Nina reached out and touched stuff.
She was touching the display
when she's not supposed to.
Huh?
Okay, next stop Mine Train.
Let's do it.
This is the line up we have to go through.
(playful jovial music)
How was it guys?
- Good!
- [Evan] How was it?
- It's already broken.
- Good!
- [Evan] Was it fun?
- Yeah!
- [Evan] Good.
- What ride are we going-
- On next?
- The Great Goofiny.
(cheering)
For the Goofy hat man.
(playful jovial music)
Got to hold on more carefully,
don't want to lose the-
At The Great Goofiny now.
- Uh Oh.
- Let's see the crazy
driver of Great Goofiny,
how good he is at driving.
- I don't think he's going
to be very good at driving.
- I think I'm going to
be way better than him.
- Nina!
(excited screaming)
- No hands!
Woo hoo!
(excited screaming)
- Whoa!
How was it?
- Awesome but, too short.
- That's what you said last year.
- Too short, way too short.
How was it Stephanie?
- Good, it was so short though.
- Everybody out.
- [Hayden] It was amazing
but way too short.
- We're going to go meet
some Disney characters,
and then go eat.
(exciting buoyant music)
Who are we going to meet guys?
- Goofy.
- [Evan] And?
- Donald.
- [Evan] Nice.
(exciting buoyant music)
- He got jealous of Goofy.
- [Evan] He didn't like your hat?
- No, he got jealous 'cause
it was Goofy not him.
(exciting buoyant music)
- [Evan] Alright it's lunchtime.
We got Clam Chowders, Tuna
Sandwiches, Apple Juices,
Yogurts, Macaroni and
Cheese, Chicken Pot Pies
and Tuna Sandwiches.
What do we think guys?
Ready to eat?
- Yeah!
- [Evan] Alright.
How is it?
- Salty.
- Amazing.
- Amazing?
Yummy.
Nina's happy, because?
- It's warm.
- It's getting warmer.
But you've got the rock solid,
look we're all in our Believe Hoodies.
- It looks bad on me.
- Who's fat on you?
- You.
- Me?
I didn't mean to do that.
- Daddy.
- [Evan] What's up?
- Are we going on the Mad
Hatter's Tea Party today?
- [Evan] Maybe.
- Please?
- [Hayden] Please?
- Maybe.
(villainous laughter)
(brisk playful music)
Next stop, The Little Mermaid.
Okay, let's go, let's go.
Me and Jeffery, chillin'
in the Clam Shell.
- How do you close this thing?
- That's fine, it's down.
Let's see what we got.
Whoa, let's go into the sea.
(brisk playful music)
What did we think?
- Good.
- [Evan] Good?
Good Nina?
- Nice.
- Hayden, nice?
Alright,
next
Peter Pan.
(suspenseful cheerful music)
How was it?
- We were actually flying.
- So cool we couldn't even see the tracks.
- [Evan] You're flying-
- We weren't on the tracks.
- Awesome.
Whoa.
- Alright, I've got to go
film a video for the channel.
So Nina's going to take
the kids to the Teacups.
Where you spin in a circle and then on the
Merry-Go-Round.
That hopefully buys me enough time
to film my video,
for you guys.
(light mellow music)
One of the things you get
when you film in public,
you get people looking at you,
wondering what is this guy doing.
(embarrassed laughing)
And you've got to talk
loudly so everything,
so the camera can pick it up and hear.
The more you do it, the more
you just get used to it.
The more you know what?
I don't care about what
these people think.
I'm more about making
something that you guys
are going to love and enjoy.
So, I got that done
pretty quickly actually,
surprisingly fast so I'm going to see if
I can pick up a copy.
A copy, a coffee for Nina
'cause she's pretty tired.
And then meet up with the kids.
(light cheerful music)
Line's not so bad today, pretty excited.
Alright, finally out,
after I got the coffees.
It's official, Starbucks
is still the longest
line at Disney.
Longer than any line
we've been in and longer
than for me to make my videos.
Whoa.
What?
We got the coffee, let's go
find Nina and make her happy.
Without getting into accidents.
(light cheerful music)
Did you have fun?
- Yeah.
(light cheerful music)
- Oh, it's yummy.
Ah.
(light cheerful music)
- [Evan] Right now what
we're doing is meeting Belle.
Stephanie wants to meet Belle.
Nina wants to meet Belle too.
- [Hayden] I want to meet Belle.
- [Evan] And Hayden wants to meet Belle.
- And Jeffery wants to meet Belle.
And I want to film.
- Come on,
come on, come on.
(tense exhilarating symphony music)
- I have to stand guard.
(magical twinkling symphony music)
How was it Mister?
Huh?
You got a bookmark?
You going to use it to read?
Alright.
(invigorating music)
We're going into a show,
I won't be allowed to film.
But, my money is that
Nina's going to fall asleep.
- Maybe, maybe.
- Nina's going to fall asleep.
I'm putting it at like 87%,
Nina's going to fall asleep.
I won't be able to film inside but,
we'll see what happens.
You guys ready for a show?
- Yes.
- [Evan] Alright.
Hayden, you ready for a show?
- No, yes.
- [Evan] No?
- Yes!
- [Evan] Alright, here we go.
Alright we're coming out.
Can't really see Nina.
Let's get some more light.
- [Hayden] Daddy, Daddy.
- [Evan] What's up?
- [Hayden] They added stuff.
- [Evan] They added stuff?
- [Hayden] Yeah.
- [Evan] Compared to last year?
Really?
- It was different from last year.
- Okay.
But the real question we want to know is,
did Nina fall asleep?
- Not really.
- She fell asleep.
You know why?
This is why.
Her head was on my shoulder,
and I felt like this.
(mumbles)
And up like that.
- I woke up. (mumbles)
- She didn't sleep a lot
but she slept a little bit.
Okay, last ride of the day.
What's the last ride of the day?
- Small world.
♫ It's a small world after all.
Let's go hit it up,
we're going to sing the song.
(lively playful music)
Time for our favorite ride.
Let's get our singing voices ready.
- Okay.
(screeching)
- Wow, don't sing like that.
♫ It's a small world after all.
♫ It's a small, small world.
(snappy joyful music)
♫ It's a small world after all.
♫ It's a small, small world.
♫ ♫ It's a small world after all.
("It's a Small World" by
Disneyland Children's Chorus)
All day it's going to be going on now.
All day.
(upbeat music)
It's time for our last stop of the day.
What are we doing?
- Ice Cream.
- Ice cream.
Yeah.
- I'm Goofy.
- [Evan] Look at this
line up to get Ice Cream.
Storybook Treats, it's
almost Starbucks level.
(upbeat music)
Alright, it's Ice Cream time.
What do you think boys?
- Good.
- [Evan] They got strawberry,
sharing a strawberry.
The girls are sharing a strawberry.
Go, eat.
Yummy?
- Yep.
- Yeah?
Alright.
Nina's stealing my chocolate.
Nina's stealing mine.
No!
Oh yeah.
(mumbles)
Good job Disney, good job.
The line up, not cool.
But the quality Ice Cream,
good job.
Alright guys, thank you
for joining us for day,
five?
- [Hayden] Five.
- Did we have fun?
- Yeah!
- Alright, we're going to
head off to Hollywood Studios
and Jedi Training , next up on our trip.
Thank you guys again.
We hope you continue to,
- [Group] Believe!
Nina, it's this way, with your right hand.
- That way?
- There you go, believe, believe,
or whatever your one word is.
- And we'll see you soon.
Everybody's stealing the show.
Thanks guys, see you soon.